the average American throws away an
estimated 185 pounds of plastic each
year scientists say a third of our
plastic trash ends up in fragile
ecosystems like our oceans one
researcher predicts there will be more
plastic in the sea than fish by 2050 and
we are already finding garbage on the
farthest ends of our planet Jonathan
Vigliotti traced our plastic trash to
the Arctic Islands in northern Norway
[Music]
time is running out for an unusual
patrol soon snow and ice will blanket
the Lofoten Islands in Norway's Arctic
Circle making this groups passage here
impossible yeah June granteth leads this
mission how many people live on this
island here actually none zero zero we
are on our own
we may be on our own but everywhere we
look there are unwanted signs of life
granteth and her team of volunteers are
on plastic patrols scouring the region
for trash the ocean cleanup began in
2012 when I first found two Marrero's
personís two birds trapped in one piece
of plastic like this trapped dead
trapped and dead on a beach
that discovery unlocked a dirty secret
this polar paradise has become a garbage
dump so this is a sampling of just some
of the things we've found so far we've
got a coca-cola carrier this is on it
that it's from Venezuela we also have
what looks like a some sort of
motorcycle helmet that's been washed up
here some of this plastic has been in
the water for so long you can't even
make out what it is in a six-year study
scientists traced Arctic plastic back to
its source
they found the global conveyor belt of
ocean currents like the Gulf Stream
carries plastic all the way from the
Americas and Europe to the Arctic where
it meets a dead end last year alone over
40 tons of plastic were collected from
the islands a recent cleanup here
produced these four bags I mean these
things are so heavy you can't even lift
it
scientists say melting ice has even
allowed plastic to travel to the
northernmost ecosystem climate change
has also made it easier for research
vessels to gain access and measure the
problem after collecting and analyzing
water samples researchers estimate there
are more than 300 billion pieces of
plastic in Arctic waters most of them
are so-called micro plastics the size of
a grain of rice broken down fragments of
bigger objects like water bottles straws
and q-tips this is what happens if you
break down milk tops I mean they're so
fire it looks like powder absolutely dr.
Carrie Lewis with England's Exeter
University says animals easily confuse
this junk for food she studies the
impact this micro plastic has on the
Arctic food chain so what happens if a
nun and all these eating what's a
plastic that plastics what gets a bit
stuck in its gut and then it starts to
feel full when it hasn't actually got
any food and so what they do is lose
weight and they don't have much energy
for reproduction and growth it's too
early to tell how threatened arctic
animals are but elsewhere around the
world
the results have been deadly which is
why Jim granteth is patrolling the
Arctic Earth's last paradise a new
frontier for pollution I do hope that
all people in the world get their eyes
open and stop polluting the ocean we
have to stop now for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti the Arctic Circle
Norway feeling a little guilty after
looking at so much plastic and just
don't think about it what's really
happening talk about eyes open just
mission accomplished